[Music]
how does it feel to be in st louis
playing in the sinkhole top it feels
good it's um
it's also one of those um rare occasions
when magnus is playing he he's i think
taken more of a back seat in terms of
like playing all the events in the world
compared to uh to a few years ago
so
i haven't played an event with him in
besides the olympiad where we didn't
we didn't play um but an event like this
with him in quite a while so that'll be
interesting of course
it feels great i mean i love playing
here in san luis
it's a home for me now and
this year is going to be very
strong
even though even magnus is playing so
sounds like a very interesting
tournament so i mean
really looking forward to it
i'm
always very happy to be in saint louis
especially now that i live here it's
going to be
of course a very strong event
as always
and
recently i had some
mediocre results
in classical chess so i would like to
this is normally my forte classical
chess so i'll try to
play better
i i like to play here because here
you play in three two tournaments every
time and
after every tournament he thinks next
will be much better and this time also i
am very happy to back play in saint
louis it's
really
just here is very important
it's a great feeling to be back in san
cris
i've been i've had the opportunity to to
enjoy a bit of the us
in the past few weeks so i'm well you
know
acquainted now no more jet lag so ready
to play ready to fight
right it's my first time to be in saint
louis um
it's a very interesting experience i
always wanted to play in one of these
tournaments in saint louis because it's
a
it's a legendary place i was always
watching growing up
um the saint louis tournament so it's
it's a pleasant experience for me and um
i really look forward to the tournament
last time i played in 2019 until
everything yeah
so
i wonder how it goes because yeah it was
pretty much up and down last time and
hopefully it will be only up this time
here so we will see i'm so glad to be
back here in st louis it really feels
like home to me
i hope to be able to
play well this year i mean my
grandchildren this year has been quite
so enso like i've
played okay in romania but then the next
two wrapping this didn't really things
didn't really go my way now i have to
see if i can turn make up for some of
the lost points here in the last leg but
i'm very glad to be back here in saint
louis all the people i know fortunately
have to focus on jeff and playing well
but
i'm very happy to be here yeah it's my
first grandchester event and playing in
america is already
not something very unique for me so even
being in america um
so obviously i'm honored to play in the
sink field cup it's like the first super
tournament that i've played in classical
so it's a great opportunity and of
course playing chess in st louis like
there's no comparison feels good to be
uh be back it's been it's been a while
now have been here for uh for three
years um
certainly this is uh as tough as the
tournament can can get basically with uh
nine
with nine opponents so
it's definitely an exciting prospect
[Music]